je vous le disais dans les titres une
enseignante d'un lycée professionnel
blésois s'est défenestrée ce vendredi
matin en plein cours un geste désespéré
depuis le deuxième étage de
l'établissement et devant ses élèves sur
place on retrouve audrey champigny pour
en savoir plus sur les circonstances de
ce drame pour les 700 élèves du lycée
professionnel sonia delaunay c'est le
choc l'incompréhension
ce matin en devant l'établissement de
petits groupes parlait textoter toute la
journée c'est une ambiance lourde
pesante qui a régné l'émotion était
palpable
soit qu'on se dispute un élève qui
faisait un malaise ou quelque chose
comme ça mais après bah on a une
professeure de sciences qu'avec nativité
de radés par fenêtre parce que ben là
quelque chose de choquant qui peut être
peut être arriver c'est un peu sous le
choc parce que je m'attendais jamais à
ce qui se passe ça et que
c'est très perturbant et et en plus ma
preuve d'ailleurs à continuer faire
court quand on a quand on a continué
pour moi c'était impossible trop
perturbé
personne bien trop j'en pleure vers 8h30
ce matin pompiers et forces de l'ordre
arrivent en nombre une personne du lycée
vient de se défenestrer du deuxième
étage une chute de huit mètres de haut
il s'agit en réalité d'une professeur
d'économie-gestion âgé d'une soixantaine
d'années qui se trouvait en cours avec
une vingtaine d'élèves ainsi que la
professeur principal de la classe
d'après les premiers éléments sans un
mot l'enseignant a remis son manteau
pris appui sur le radiateur est ouvert
la fenêtre avant de se jeter dans le
vide encore consciente à l'arrivée des
secours elle a été transférée à
l'hôpital de blois où elle a été opérée
des membres inférieurs son pronostic
vital n'est plus engagé et immédiatement
on a de très bonnes relations avec le
samu qu'on avait déjà rencontré
malheureusement dans d'autres
circonstances dramatiques donc je les ai
appelés dès qu'on a été informé et sont
venus et ont eu donc de leur côté ont
pris en charge des élèves qui avaient
été directement témoin c'est à dire les
élèves qui étaient en classe et des
élèves qui ont vu l'enseignant de tomber
et puis pour ce qui concerne la déesse
de haine on est venu aussi avec nos
personnels pour pouvoir accompagner le
reste de la classe également mais
également l'ensemble des personnels du
lycée parce qu'il ya une grande émotion
et un choc parce que là si tu vois là
c'était absolument pas prévisible et
c'est très compliqué pour tout le monde
enseignants et personnels ont pu se
retrouver dans la matinée pour un temps
des changes les cours de ce vendredi ont
été suspendus l'établissement est
néanmoins resté ouvert pour accueillir
les internes mais également les élèves
qui souhaitaient aller à l'infirmerie
une enquête est en cours pour définir
les circonstances exactes de ce drame